real welcome the really happy you guys
all could be here today's talk is about
exploratory data analysis and
visualization for image segmentation
challenge but before I dive into the
talk like just a slide mandatory yeah
information about me um exercise I'm
working here is ML engineer in ml and
day in day out I basically work with
scaling and productizing machine
learning models so that's my main job
also on the side I work in as faculty in
Tilburg University so we have data
science department in Den Bosch and I'm
sitting there for hours a week before I
was also in this region in Eindhoven
working with philips Lighting now it's
known as signify on the side I'm really
passionate about spreading knowledge of
data science to the community at large
so PI data is one of the initiators I'm
quite passionately involved with and
also on the side I do a bit of weekend
cackling so this talk is more about that
part it's not really anything to do with
work
and also on the side we have started
with a small organization called open
DAC and through this we try to
contribute more educational content on
github like I have code repositories
that teach a spark and then my
colleagues from the same organization
contributes to teaching free machine
learning courses ok that's enough about
me
today's talk is about image segmentation
first I'm just going to cover like
typical challenges that you can do with
images right so you have first
classification right where you just want
to say that yeah this has a certain
element or it doesn't then you have
object detection where you are giving
coordinates like okay yeah we have hot
air balloon here and this is where the
balloons are semantics a segmentation
right that's basically what we're going
to go into now and this is where we give
the layer or so we are basically
predicting for every pixel whether the
content exists or not right so for this
for air balloons we say okay these are
the pixels which actually has hot air
balloons
dokoni okay ah okay and then there's
instant segmentation where we are doing
the pixel labeling as well as each
instance office so we are able to say
okay we have a one hot air balloon two
hot air balloons just like this and
today we're going to look into this
semantics so image segmentation in terms
of data format for those who are not
really familiar with working with images
of course we have like the image data
and then we have the labels right like
your that stuff you train with so that
image data and the label is also known
as mask because it's code of overlays on
top of the image like a mask and
typically in this challenges you would
be designing and developing machine
learning models cnn's
to have an output like the one on the
right like mask right so we feed the
models in the end Wayne is working very
well the image data and we expect the
mask as the output after the model has
been trained but we're not going to go
into the modeling today it's about doing
the basic right fundamental fundamental
fundamental so before we go to the
modeling it's really important to
understand what kind of data you have
and typically with a images since you
don't have yeah a lot of other data like
it's not highly highly highly
dimensional like it doesn't have a lot
of variables and stuff so you just feed
it into the model and I'm going to show
you all the stuff that you can do with
image data to do EDS so like I said
that's the content of today it's about
Kaggle and if you are not on cable yet
it should be there Carol is where we
should be spending our weekends guys so
yeah I've participated in three
competitions on Kaggle and offer those
three competitions I also did three
idiots and those three ideas also got
gold medals and I'm basing the talk on
those three EDS today and I'm not going
to go through the full notebook I'm just
going to take some highlights and talk
about that but you can find this slide
later on and also those notebooks
and you can see the full detail of it
and I've also simplified the
visualizations a lot because it doesn't
make sense for PowerPoint the first
challenge is pneumothorax which is when
you have buildup of gas in your lungs so
in this competition it's really about
helping patients when they have all of a
sudden a collapsed lung and typically
you don't even go to the medical center
apparently to get this checked up it's
something that just comes up because
they're doing your chest x-ray for some
other reason and radiologists are are
quite often ignoring them because
they're not really trained to look into
air they're more interested in your
bones and etc so this competition was
about training ml model so you can do
segmentation of the area where gas might
have been a built up on the lines so
there's about 12 K data and nice thing
about this competition was that there
was also meta data available so that's
quite rare for image segmentation
challenges right and here's a link to my
kernel and it you'll see it's quite
difficult to see pneumothorax like it's
not if this is actually one of the
easiest one where pneumothorax there is
a buildup and they press the next one
that's basically the region where it's
happening and if I overlay the mask on
top of it that's exactly where the gas
buildup is right and if you're not going
in for this checkup is quite normal for
the radiologist to ignore it so yeah I
should be able to help out for this case
and here in this one as always there is
a huge class imbalance so you don't you
have like a lot of no numerator as an
example but like not enough of the
positive cases also another thing to
mention is that it may happen that you
have gas buildup in multiple regions so
I quickly did like plot to see okay
typically how many regions you see
develop so this is of course the first
thing we do when we go into a
computation see how much what's like
your distribution of data and if you
have more than one segmentation per
image furthermore here in this case you
have like the age and gender so one
obvious thing to do was to like
really see okay if there is a difference
between H for example for the patients
and then also for the gender right so
yeah should I make it stop yeah just
being more interactive okay so nobody
had a problem when it was spinning okay
yeah so there is a nice box plot and you
do see like hey for really like for new
motor X people with new motor X you mean
and Max is pretty high so some hint of
data leakage there for kegels it's fine
but real life yeah leakage doesn't help
so no there's not really much in terms
of age and in terms of gender right but
it's good to know that we have some meta
data and we can further go on to our
investigation so another nice thing here
is that in the meta data they have this
field called pixel spacing so because
it's in this highly standardized medical
image capturing format they have this
concept of actually giving you like the
physical space in patients chest and
what it means on the pixel to pixel
distance so sort of like this you have
like the column spacing and row spacing
and in that part you would know like
okay what is approximately the area and
we have also the mask right so if you
actually count the nonzero elements of
the mask you can sort of estimate what
is the size of the build up and that's
also a nice thing to do in this
particular challenge so that's exactly
what I did
I went on to measure the size of the
build up of the gas for different age
groups for example and with that I
plotted this out and what I did here was
I took the age and I just categorized it
into four different groups like child
yield a adult and senior and then did
the boxplot of the area sorry I really
couldn't scale so you see like this
scale for I mean they're not really
scaled in the same way but anyway more
for me to learn on partly yeah there is
definitely quite a strong relation with
the size of the lungs of course and here
area where you're going to have a build
up so childs typically have to have a
smaller region per se and what was
interesting though is like you'd like
that yeah group they had higher
yeah median and q3 as well then adults
so I don't I'm not a radiologist I can't
really work and but our interpret this
but these are just my findings so yeah
we do see that there are some unique
characteristics for groups and gender in
terms of also outlier and so on I wanted
to find out a little bit more so this
particular image if you notice there is
like full gist but our point of interest
is just the lungs and there are
pre-trained models so there was
competitions before where we did have
pre trained models to do lung
segmentation so if we can take out just
the lung I have more insights so that's
what I try to do using a pre trained
model to do image segmentation and just
take out the rest of it for training
it's not a good idea of course because
you want the noise to be there but this
is just for insights so there was a
particular pre-trained model that I
tried to use here you see it works quite
okay for male patient but actually when
I tried it for my female patient data
set it was not really working so well
because probably like also you have like
yeah like the breast formation and that
maybe causes the module to cut confused
but that's also interesting maybe like
you know this also starts giving all at
least it started giving me a hint on how
I should train my data and if I should
have separate models and terms of
different groups and then do that
because I that's also in the data like
age and sex so I can feed it to two
different networks if I wanted to okay
so then the second challenge I'm really
good at I'm okay second challenge is
about steal defect detection so this
particular challenge is about detecting
different type of defects defects on
steel and of course motor modern society
would not really be possible without
you and our aim here is to make this
production process more efficient and
here you have actually some multi closed
problems so you have like four type of
defects that's the four type right over
there and there is about two about
twelve and a half K images and they're
sort of high resolution sort of and this
is basically my kernel link so first off
like as always I'm just going to check
with like the different classes and like
how well they're represented and you see
like your type three years like way way
way way high represented and the rest is
not so well represented and furthermore
there is also a lot of images weed out
any defects which is fine for a lot of
use cases but here actually the defect
doesn't really occur in the whole image
it's quite a small space so the network
itself already has enough information or
noise in the image where there is defect
to understand also what is not a defect
so these in the end actually I didn't
really need to use the information about
where the yeah there are no defects
because no defects is also included in
images with defects right there are
regions which is fine so here for
example we don't have any metadata and
if you were to do any further Adu just
be like okay I'm done let's just start
doing modeling but that's often like
from my experience is not a good idea
and remember you still have the mask so
when you are in trouble like you are in
a plane the pressure drops use your mask
and here what I did because there are
like all the images all the all the
images are sort of scaled in the same
way you can count like the number of
pixels you have purse mask and get an
approximation of the surface area right
as a proxy figure per se so it would
allow you to better understand the class
because just because I have 10000
example of a particular class doesn't
mean that I have a lot of real estate in
the image of that class right maybe
they're really tiny
and the network will have difficult time
finding out about these and that's what
I did so I started well this put this
plot here on the left this basically is
just like your PI plot showing like a
per class what
what is its contribution and then on the
other side I just took like the area for
the defects from the mask and what you
see is interesting is like for class one
you have like 12.6% of like the whole
data set so it seems like okay it's not
bad representation like you would think
like only class two is like the one
that's really struggling but you really
see on the right like yeah actually you
have maybe a lot of examples but in
terms of the total area those are really
really small examples so you need to pay
a really attention or your network needs
to pay more attention to those area
right and in terms of class four you see
that yeah it's about eleven point three
percent but it goes up so these areas
maybe are bigger right so maybe these
are really big errors so we can even do
one level better and what can we do here
is really simple you have multiple
defects segment right and we can win and
we should basically count these segments
but this is not given in the data set
like the data set is just one layer of
mask but you can write a simple function
using OpenCV to basically understand the
threshold right those masks it's just
usually binary and in this case it is
binary so you can just understand the
threshold and count the contours and
then understand okay for this defect for
this image I have eight spots right so
now you have another variable to work
with so that's what I did and if I
basically take the average segments
power defect and plot it out and then
also like the average size so there is
just a pixel count just a proxy figure
per defect what we notice is quite
interesting we see that like for type 1
and type for type 2 the number of
average is quite low so basically type 2
typically comes in just one or two small
pieces
and type 1 are like scattered many small
spot spots in terms of area both of them
are really small right so that's
interesting and 4 type 4 we see that the
areas for each segment even they're
large so these are actually really chunk
big chunk of error and you can of course
go all nevel deeper and maybe just group
them out so if you say that ok the
number of segments 5 to 10 is in one
bucket 10 plus is one bucket you see
actually further my point like type 2 is
really tend to come like in a really
tiny small spot and rest of the stuff
are somewhat similar but remember
they're not really underrepresented
except for type 3 so this actually was
quite handy for me to do before I went
into the main competition and if I
summarize everything up
type 1 it tends to be small in size and
typically comes in like many small
segments right like so these are just
like two examples one of them I just put
there like yeah it can't happen that it
just once instance and then on the
bottom you see there are like three
instances type two it tends to typically
come also in like small size but not in
large numbers just in small numbers and
then type three we see here like over
there and you see like that can come
either like in 3 or 5 or 10 and 15 but
then the area surface area is a bit
larger but then when I actually
physically look into the images that you
see sometimes it's large because the
errors are very near each other but
they're not going to go into that much
detail now but yeah but in terms of
surface area for the network to work
with there's a lot for type 3 and
interestingly enough also for type 4 so
type 4 even though it's not a huge image
sample you have a lot of real estate to
work with here
so when I first did like the model to
like do the segmentation type 1 and type
2 and also like the open source when I
committed you see there it's really
difficult for you to find unless you
come up with a better
strategy for training right like you can
let's say do image augmentation and then
up sample type 1 and type 2 but straight
of the box I tried I believe like
receive res unit and for that type 3 and
type 4 did not need any fine-tuning and
high 4 is actually not that many ok and
final competition and then we're done so
the final one is about understanding
clouds like not like Google cloud or
Amazon really the cloud and from here we
are asked to basically classify the type
of cloud formation for metrologist of
course climate change is one of the most
pressing issues of our time and this
competition is supposed to help people
like professionals understand why these
clouds are forming in an automated way
and then better understand like how we
are changing the climate so that reminds
me the booty back you received today are
fully sustainable and decomposable and
so we are trying to do our part here ok
and yeah the images are quite quite like
high resolution and there is not that
many of them right so there is like
about 5.5 K images and here is my ETA
find me in the clouds so as always check
out the number of labels you have and
you have yeah what kind of defects you
have perm image so these are the four
types of cloud formation they call them
sugar gravel fish flour and for once
it's not imbalance so it's nice
competition if you see the number of
cloud formations you typically tend to
find in a single image it's actually
more than one typically right so that's
the night that's an interesting thing
already like these formations of course
in an image is a pretty big image so you
would find two to three per image so
it's good for you to understand that and
know that so you don't spoil just start
chopping up the image and feeding the
full blown image to the net
yeah Network needs to have more context
in that case right and in cases like
this where you have multi class and you
have nice balance in between the classes
one thing you can do is do frequent
pattern and I think everybody almost
here knows about frequent pattern but
just to just for bookkeeping sake I've
made some few statements about what it
is so it's basically like about like
your simple Association rule right like
you just want to see which items are
very frequently in an item set and so if
a restaurant was just selling like beer
pizza and other food like this icons are
showing here so all the transactions
right if you denote them as T and the
event like people order people at least
order drinks and pizza put that as X you
would have a support of like count of X
/ count of T and you use supporters like
sort of like a threshold to move away
the stuff you don't care about and keep
the patterns that you like so using
frequent pattern mining what I did was I
went through the data set and see which
cloud formations occur very frequently
and there are clearly some patterns so
some cloud formations definitely happen
more frequently than others and then
there are some that occur less than
others but the main most important thing
is all those all kinds of cloud
formation can appear together in the
image just some are more likely than
others right so that's also important in
your training or how you design the
architecture or how you resize the image
that okay so we are at the end of the
top and I think I do the PI data event a
favor if I can finish a little bit early
hope I wasn't going too fast
to summarize basically we have metadata
and if you are lucky enough to have
metadata use it and you can also combine
it with the mask to make even more more
more plots if you're not lucky to have
metadata you always have your mask so
use it to calculate the area see how
many segments you have
this sort of thing if you have a pre
train model to do additional
segmentation onto a point of interest
instead of the whole thing that may be
able to help you but not often is useful
because you know all models are a little
bit biased right so for your image set
maybe the pre training model doesn't
work so well and finally if you have
imbalance class and there are multiple
classes you can use frequent pattern
mining and that should be able to
produce some additional insight so that
is basically my top for today just one
last slide thank you for coming to buy
data on Dovan it's like really really
special for me to be able to do this for
the first time I'm not born here like a
lot of people but I my professional
career mostly revolves around here so
I'm really really happy that so many
people turned up and we're able to do
this and big thanks to SML as well for
enabling this yep so final final slide
these are my profile so if you want to
connect please reach out to me via
LinkedIn or gaggle there are some
courses I made on github and yeah that's
it for today thank you
[Applause]